as America flattens the curve questions
arise about what comes next the media be
clown themselves with a variety of
foolish narratives and Alyssa Milano
discovers due process i'm ben shapiro
this is the ben shapiro show today's Ben
Shapiro show is sponsored by expressive
VPN your online activity should not be
public protect yourself at Express at
VPN dot-com / Ben all righty well time
for door coronavirus updates because
once more this is the only thing
happening on planet earth in the news at
all and it's the only thing anybody
cares about which makes perfect sense
the United States has passed 11,000
total deaths this comes basically a week
and a half after we were less than 3000
that the United States is seeing a
significant curve in terms of cumulative
deaths but in terms of new cases we're
not seeing cumulative growth it looks
more arithmetic than cumulative it's a
percentage of the new tests that are
being taken we are not saying a sharp
uptick in the number of new cases that
are being that are out there more just
an uptick in the number of cases that
are identified as we are doing more
testing yesterday New York saw 599
deaths according to world ometer x'
which is the Johns Hopkins rip did
overall the United States yesterday so
about twelve hundred and fifty-five
deaths these are not good numbers
obviously but we are starting to see the
curve flatten somewhat and everybody is
sort of optimistic right Andrew Cuomo in
New York
he said the data are hopeful but
inconclusive at this point here's the
governor of New York
this is hopeful but it's also
inconclusive and it still depends on
what we do right these models all have a
coefficient of what we do and how
successful we are social distancing etc
and from our decision-making point of
view it doesn't really matter if we've
hit the plateau or not because you have
to do the same thing if we are
plateauing we are plateauing at a very
high level and this tremendous stress on
the healthcare system ok so he has said
that the coronavirus deaths have been
flat that's the plateau that he is
talking about the idea is that if you
keep having that number of deaths day
after day after day that's bad
eventually want that number to go down
we have not hit the peak yet the peak is
expected to hit sometime it later
this week the study that everybody had
been using in order to determine exactly
how many deaths there would be is of
course that university of washington
study and they had projected that
overall peak resource use in the united
states would not happen until april
fifteenth 2020 in new york they were
expecting that this thing would happen
just a little bit later this week it
wasn't it was going to precede the rest
of the United States they have
downgraded as I mentioned yesterday the
number of total deaths to 82,000 in that
University of Washington model Andrew
Cuomo says the coronavirus deaths are
indeed flat which is again good news I
mean if we're continuing to go up then
that would be a little bit scarier and
again the the number of Crona virus
deaths if we were to plateau exactly
where we are in the United States that
would be some very very good news
because we're expecting that this thing
is supposed to kill some 3,000 people by
the middle of the month in a single day
and right now and we're at about
thirteen hundred which is ugly but it is
nowhere near three thousand there's
Andrew Cuomo pointing out the corona
virus deaths have been flat in New York
City four thousand seven hundred and
fifty-eight which is up from 159 but
which is effectively flat for two days
while none of this is good news the
flattening possible flattening of the
curve is better than the increases that
we have seen big question that we're
looking at now is what what is the curve
and we've been talking about cases
increase increase increase until they
don't when they stop increasing then
what happens and that is the real
question is where we go from here so
what you're seeing from cities all over
the nation is an attempt to keep people
in their homes that sometimes takes very
dystopian forms we've seen people being
pulled over in places like Pennsylvania
for literally just going for a joy ride
like literally just getting in a car and
driving there's nothing wrong with that
it's absurd one of the big problems when
you have an emergency is that petty
tyrants often emerge and then use their
petty tyranny as an excuse
in order to do really stupid things
there's nothing wrong with getting in
your car and going for a drive their
kids and then driving right back home I
do with my kids all the time because
anybody with kids understands you must
do this or your kids will go completely
mad
rip all of the windows off the hinges
and start hitting each other with them
you need to get them outside if there's
no place to go outside sometimes you
throw them in the car to go for an hour
drive that is not a big deal you have
not hurt the social distancing curve all
of this is very stupid
it has also taken the form of some
pretty freaky video in New York City
where the police have been using drones
to tell people to socially distance
doesn't I get it I do but it's kind of
weird here's here's this video from New
York City I think that that's
particularly effective having drones
that are flying above walkways and
telling people to socially distance
presumably not and I look forward to
judge dredd arriving to do justice in
the middle of all of this now the reason
that obviously there's an amount of
focus that there is on these death
totals and on the curve is the fact that
the experts keep saying that we can only
lower the curve we continue to keep
people indoors but they are afraid of is
that people are gonna say oh looks like
things are all better and then they rush
out of doors and they infect each other
over and over so dr. Deborah Burt's was
of course leading up the coronavirus
task force for the White House
she said the death totals could be a lot
lower than we were seeing from the
University of Washington but only if we
work hard and only if we pay attention
to the orders of social existence in
stay at home
dr. Fauci and I both strongly believe
that if we work as hard as we can over
the next several weeks that we will see
potential to go under the numbers that
were predicted by the models and I think
that is really two things it is the
extraordinary compliance of the American
people and the due diligence that they
have mitigated with because remember
we're doing this strictly by behavior
change and and as she says there's not a
lot of tracking in place right now
basically I guess the goal is that we
lower the curve again below the point
where we overwhelm the hospital system
as the University of Washington study
shows that actually is likely we are now
likely to
not exceed the requirements of the
hospital system actually as we adjust
these totals downward but the question
is gonna be what happens afterward and
listen I'm all for the hopeful language
again I like it I think it's good I
think that we we ought to continue to
maintain this sort of thing until we
have the data the problem is that now
that the data seems to be showing that
we are flattening faster than we
actually thought was going to be
possible how fast can we actually get
back to some semblance of normalcy dr.
Anthony Fauci also sounds it off along
with alongside deborah birx he said we
too are hopeful I don't think anyone has
ever mitigated the way I'm seeing people
mitigate right now this has never
happened in this country before so I am
optimistic always cautiously optimistic
that if we do what I've been talking
about over the past few minutes we can
make that number go down I don't accept
every day that we're gonna have to have
a hundred to two hundred thousand deaths
I think we can really bring that down no
matter what a model says okay so
everybody is suddenly optimistic in a
way they were not optimistic just a
little while ago we'll get to what the
studies are showing what the data are
showing and what are the shortcomings of
those data because as it turns out all
the models are basically flawed and
everybody knew this going in and what
that creates is a sort of unfalsifiable
thesis because every time the data are
adjusted downward we just say okay well
we're adjusting the model as new data
comes in and then the idea becomes okay
well but you modeled with a certain
level of certainty what exactly
everything would look like in the
counterfactual if we had not all locked
down or if we had done sort of partial
lock downs or if we had let the
healthiest people go to work or if we
had taken the elderly and we had
basically segmented them off and then
the vulnerable and segments and them up
like we were basing our action on these
models and as the models change our
actions should change but our actions
seem not to be changing even as the
models change because nobody has set out
any sort of reliable counterfactual in
that case to give a brief example that
suggests that the United States
experiencing well under 80 thousand
deaths let's say the United States comes
in at say 50 thousand deaths or 40
thousand deaths like right in line with
the actual numbers that you get every
year from the fluid now of course the
flu those number of deaths happened when
we were all like going out infecting
each other and this is happening in the
ABS
of us going out and infecting each other
but let's say we get 40,000 tests it'll
be two narratives that emerge and this
is the highest likelihood here is that
we actually do a pretty good job in
flattening in the curve it's fewer
deaths than expected in the first wave
and then you have one side that says
okay so the models were totally wrong
and we destroyed the entire American
economy and we went to 20% unemployment
on the basis of models that were wrong
why did we pursue it this way and the
other side says well if we hadn't
pursued it this way then millions would
be dead and there's not going to be any
way to bridge that gap at all right
because you can't live in a
counterfactual universe because we
actually don't know the counterfactuals
the models were supposed to provide the
counterfactual but how are you supposed
to trust the models worst case scenario
when they're moderated worst case
scenario meaning even if you stay
indoors 100,000 people are gonna die
what if the numbers come in way under
that well that sort of discredits the
entire model and this is one of the
problems that we're gonna have going
forward because one of the ways that the
experts and the folks who are in charge
and scientists are going to suggest that
we stay indoors is again suggesting the
counterfactual and a lot of people are
gonna look at the counterfactual say
right right but you suggested a
counterfactual like a few months ago and
you said two and a half million people
were gonna die and then you said if we
all stay indoors still 1/4 million
people are gonna die and so we all did
stay indoors and 40,000 people died or
30,000 people died right and so why
should we take seriously your worst-case
scenario like what do you know that we
don't and the answer is that a lot of
the experts still know more than the
average man I'm not proclaiming that I
am an epidemiologist I think it's
dangerous for anybody to proclaim that I
still think the experts know a lot but
they don't know a lot - and they're not
being transparent about what it is they
don't know and that actually is going to
undermine faith in the experts at a time
when the experts are suggesting that we
have to listen to them no matter what
right I mean that's that's the biggest
problem here if you have somebody who
proclaims expertise on a subject and
then they're wrong and a bunch of things
and they haven't told you where the
uncertainties lie it makes everybody
pretty nervous about the expertise
sometimes it makes people feel that the
institution itself is discredited and
that's dangerous Whiterun radical
transparency is necessary and you need
an explainer out there explaining the
models you need an explainer out there
explaining why we are doing what we're
doing but the truth is I'm not sure that
the politicians or the economists or the
health care professionals the
epidemiologists actually know full scale
why we are doing what we are doing in
long run we'll get to that in just like
this really is catch-as-catch-can
right this really is that we are we are
betting that maybe worst case scenario
happens in a couple
million people died and so we sort of
just said lock it down right that was
the first move just lock it down and now
that that has been made the the extreme
where do you go from here that's the
really tough question I keep harping on
that cuz it's pretty important that we
end what is going on right now I mean
Tony Blair of the Labour Party right he
was saying listen the NHS is gonna
collapse if the economy collapses so you
talk about the health care service in in
Britain you can't keep taking out
endless debt then paying for the health
care service because why don't that is
not sellable it will get to more of this
in just one second first let us talk
about the fact that there are lots of
things in life you get wrong like for
example everybody got everything wrong
on everything with regard to coronavirus
except for like a couple of people well
it is it is very easy to get things
wrong in life whether you are a pundit
or whether you're just a person going
about your daily business one thing that
you cannot afford to get wrong is your
life insurance if you're a responsible
human being one of the things that you
should be doing is taking out life
insurance if you got a family and you
want to make sure that your revenue
stream does not stop in case you plotz
well you need to make sure that your
family is taking care of get life
insurance with policy genius.com policy
genius makes finding the right life
insurance a breeze in minutes you can
compare quotes from the top insurers and
find your best price you could say
fifteen hundred bucks or more every year
by using policy genius to compare life
insurance policies once you apply the
policy genius team will handle all the
paperwork and the red tape for free and
policy genius doesn't just make life
insurance easy they can also help you
find the right home and auto insurance
disability insurance so even if you look
back on the decisions that you made over
the course of the past years and think
yourself man shoulda done that
differently there's no reason to get
life insurance wrong or home insurance
or auto insurance or disability
insurance and now by the way the rates
are pretty good it's a good time to shop
go check out policy genius.com right now
everybody get them gets things wrong do
not get your life insurance wrong policy
genius con again that's policy
genius.com okay so let's take a look at
some of these models so first of all an
MIT economist is already saying that the
curve is basically flattening which
again is a lot earlier than originally
thought according to according to Robert
for brueggen over at the over at
National Review he is suggesting that
that MIT economist concludes that the
curve is indeed flattening in New York
City and that does bode well for other
cities actually you can see the trend
lines it's flattening in New Jersey it's
flattening in Michigan even though
Michigan obviously is having the scale
uptick in number of deaths la has been
basically flattening none of the curbs
look exponential in terms of confirmed
cases all of the curves look like this
and all the curves look like they are
flattening out and that's a very good
little parabolic that's that's very good
thing I mean that that's exactly what we
are looking for the growth rate in new
cases continues to slow in New York the
change in the growth rate day over day
is is four point one percent down
California four point one percent down
Washington four point seven percent down
Michigan seven point six percent down
Massachusetts six point seven percent
down the slowing transmission is
beginning to reduce deaths in New York
City the number of daily deaths has
actually been decreasing since the
weekend which indicates a decreasing
strain on medical systems and reduces
worries that hospitals will be
overwhelmed with corona virus cases now
remember there's a lot of worry about
ventilators being having to be rationed
there wasn't it there one can be an
event Slater's on order well Admiral
Brett sure are who is the Assistant
Secretary of Health and Human Services
he says listen to everybody who needs a
ventilator has gotten one so far right
there's not been anybody who's walked
into the hospital and somebody says okay
sorry all our ventilators are used
you're gonna have to die here in the
waiting room here is Admiral Brett - are
we look at ventilator use granularly
every single day in every single state
and down to the hospital level so we
have been able to meet and easily meet
all the ventilator requirements that
have been brought us to us by the state
no one it has not gotten a ventilator
that needs a ventilator and as far as we
can project looking at all models every
person who needs a ventilator will get a
ventilator we Daniel 10 railroad sorry
is the author of this piece of national
review looking over sort of the the
record by the way it is interesting the
focus on ventilators will get to the
hydroxychloroquine question in just a
little bit cuz people are still going
nuts over Trump mentioning
hydroxychloroquine there's no it's an
unconfirmed treatment it's known come
let me explain something about
ventilators once you're on events later
you are in serious serious trouble
okay this Sunday we had on a we had on a
doctor from using University of
California San Francisco and we talked
specifically about what ventilator use
means he said anywhere from 50 to 90
percent of people on ventilators will
die okay so the idea that the ventilator
is sort of the cure-all I understand
it's the last gasp measure but you know
it is not a last-gasp measure at least
not to that extent is hydroxy
Queen right you start to degrade and
they give you hydroxychloroquine okay
you're right there have not been any
clinical trials of hydroxychloroquine
one of the reasons there have not been
any clinical trials of
hydroxychloroquine is because it's
basically unethical to have two people
in a room and then randomly select one
of them to get hydroxy right you can't
do that instead you have to ask people
what they are willing to do informed
consent is still an element of clinical
trials and you can't actually tell
people who are dying we're not going to
give you this experimental drug that is
basically off-label you can't tell
people you're not going to do that so
while the media are fulminating over
hydroxychloroquine they are
simultaneously suggesting that
ventilators are the most important
single thing that any hospital can have
at this point
the fact is ventilators are important
but you know what else is SuperDuper
important coming up with mitigating
medications at this point and if that
means it's experimental if that means
that the only evidence for it is
anecdotal so far well the last thing you
want is to not have that and then end up
on the ventilator the ventilator is not
where you want to be in a second I want
to go back through the question of
modeling because again it's based on
these models that we are making the
decisions and that's okay right as the
models change we need to update our
decision-making processes and some of
the solutions that have been put forward
are just not realistic like when people
are talking about contract racing in the
United States the question is how you
contact race in a country of 330 million
people where people are fairly used to
not being monitored by the government
South Korea has had contact tracing in
place since 2003 since the SARS outbreak
in the United States what are we going
to do ramp up contact tracing now when
we have community infection and when the
testing is not complete if you're
talking about ramping it up to the point
where you have a million tests a day for
people who are symptomatic and that you
are then gonna contact race when the
number of cases goes all the way down to
zero then you could talk about if that
seems fairly unrealistic I mean it seems
fairly unrealistic we're gonna get to
the point where we are contact tracing
every single person who has corona virus
in the United States when we have in the
United States at last count 350,000
cases of corner virus that have just
been identified and tons of people who
are asymptomatic maybe up to five to ten
times that number that's gonna be pretty
damn difficult so we'll get to more of
this in just one second first let's talk
about the fact that now it's pretty
stressful time and if you have some sort
of genetic predisposition to losing your
hair like most guys do two out of three
dudes are going to
in some form of male pattern baldness by
the time they're 35 now would be
exacerbating that hair loss well what
you actually need are the approved
clinical drugs that are useful in
preventing hair loss how can you do this
do this easily not spend a lot of money
and get it delivered directly to your
home well this is where it keeps comes
in I've been using keeps because male
pattern baldness runs in my family I
enjoy my hair or what is left of it and
you should enjoy your hair too the fact
is that the that keeps is the best way
for you up to - obtain these
fda-approved products you don't have to
go broke to avoid going bald keeps
offers generic versions of the only two
fda-approved hair loss products out
there some of you may have tried them
before not for this price prevention is
key because keeps treatments really do
work they're up to 90 percent effective
and reducing and stopping further hair
loss the sooner you start using keeps
the more hair you're going to save so
act fast you know you think you're young
and the hair will be there forever
wrong you are it will go go check how it
keeps right now keeps his revolutionized
the way men are treated for hair loss
thanks to keeps don't have to go to the
doctor's office for their hair loss
prescription you can't even do that
anyway right now anyway so instead check
out keeps calm find out why keeps has
more five-star reviews than any of its
competitors and nearly 100,000 men trust
keeps for their hair loss prevention
medication for a limited time get your
first month for free that's one hell of
a deal forgetting to keep your hair go
check them out right now
ke EPS calm / man and that's ke EPS calm
/ man keeps calm / been to receive your
first month of treatment for free go
check them out right now keeps calm /
pen okay so as I have mentioned because
the models have been so variable it
makes it difficult for people to trust
experts when experts say you need to
stay in your house and especially when
they say things like you're supposed to
stay in your house indefinitely in
social distance from your own family
inside your house so what we have seen
is that the models have been
dramatically downgraded so model that's
been getting the most press in the
United States is the University of
Washington model I talked about this
pretty extensively yesterday they
dramatically downgraded over the weekend
the number of expected national deaths
from ninety four thousand to eighty one
thousand they also really really
dramatically downgraded the number of
hospital beds they thought would be
necessary and originally they thought
that the number of hospital beds that
were going to be necessary that was
going to that that was going to actually
be a lot a lot higher they thought the
number of hospital beds that was gonna
be necessary it could stack up at some
like it's something like 260,000 by
August by August 5th instead they
decreased that number to 140,000 which
is a decline of 120,000 ICU beds needed
at peak they went from 39,000 727 down
to 29,000 210 which is a decline of over
10,000 ICU beds invasive ventilators
needed a peak they went down from 32,000
all the way down to 19,000 those are
really significant changes in the in the
data that they have been providing to us
and so the question becomes why did the
changes occur well the first thing to
understand about that University of
Washington model everybody is relying
upon is it's a curve fitting model so
there's certain models that sort of
attempt to model out what disease
vectors look like by looking at
particular factors and then speculating
but the the IMA cheat model actually
attempts to just use data as it comes
and then fit the curve to the data
that's coming in so originally they were
using the Wu hen data then they were
using the Italy data and now as they're
starting to get us data it looks like us
data is actually pretty different from
Italy data and also from Wuhan data
Robert Verbruggen has good explanation
here and National Review says the I MHC
model is very different from the
Imperial College model that drew a lot
of attention a few weeks back the
Imperial College model simulated how a
virus spreads through a population based
on a host of assumptions about how
easily the disease jumps from one person
to another and how often people come
into contact with each other under
various social distancing rules the IMA
Qi model by contrast simply looks at
what has actually happened elsewhere in
the world during this outbreak and then
uses that information to predict what
will happen in the US and individual
states that means that the IMA Qi model
is a lot more malleable because as new
data puts in the curve itself changes as
opposed to as theta comes in in the
Imperial College model you have to
actually go in and change the factors
that are being used in order to
calculate that model so when the group
released their new predictions which
came out just yet two days ago they put
out a big explanation including a
salient bit regarding deaths they said
at the time of our first release on
March 26 the only location where the
number of daily deaths had already
peaked was Wuhan City these data from
Wuhan formed the basis of our estimation
of the time from the implementation of
social distancing policies to the peak
day of deaths one of the reasons that
they were in fact saying that was a
longer curve to peak day of deaths is
because China was lying about its
numbers they started seeing mass death
very early
then it tailed off really fast which is
why what you saw in the updated numbers
from the University of Washington model
is a quick rise to Apex
and then a fairly steep decline from
apex since then in additional seven
locations in Italy and Spain with large
coronavirus epidemics appear to have
reached the peak number of daily deaths
that be in Spain and then Italy but
today's update they say we now estimate
the time from implementation of social
distancing policies to the peak of daily
deaths using all eight locations where
the number of daily deaths appear to be
peaking or to have peaked the time of
implementation of social distancing to
the peak of the epidemic is shorter than
what was observed in wuhan because china
has been lying by the way NBC News doing
yeoman's work parroting all Chinese
propaganda they had a story out today
that they tweeted out saying America
experiences over 1,200 deaths China
reports no new deaths
yeah.well trying to report no deaths of
Tiananmen Square also so it turns out
that a communist country is a lying
country also they dramatically
downgraded in this study what they
thought Hospital capacity would be
necessary originally they'd suggested a
ratio of 11.1 hospital admissions per
Koba 19 death now they're saying 7.1
hospitalizations Perko bed 19 death and
that means that what they were doing is
they were just multiplying the number of
expected deaths by the number of
hospital admissions so you saw the rate
of death go down and you saw they're in
a hospital admission go down and so the
result is fewer hospital beds needed and
less of a chance of overwhelming the
system Andrew Cuomo yesterday by the way
said they don't have a hospital bed
problem in New York City he said they
might still have a ventilator problem
but that has not actually materialized
in terms of being overwhelmed at this
point and in terms of hospital beds that
apparently is not a problem anymore
the uncertainty in the modeling is both
a good thing in the sense that if the
models were certain and right that'd be
very scary it's also a problem because
if you are making all of your decisions
off of variable models then there gonna
be a lot of questions to be asked about
how well those decisions are being made
we'll get some more of this in just one
second first let's talk about the fact
that if you're having car trouble right
now Rock Auto is an absolute godsend
right you don't want to be going out to
the store in order to get a power car
for part for your car instead you should
be using the interwebs just like you are
for everything else and Rock Auto not
only has a better selection than your
local auto parts store you can get the
parts cheaper than your local auto parts
store the rockauto.com catalog is unique
it is easy to navigate
rockauto.com has everything from engine
control modules and brake parts to tail
lamps motor oil even new carpet whether
it is for your class
our daily driver get everything you need
in a few easy clicks delivered directly
to your door Rocko Auto comm always
offers the lowest price as possible
rather than changing prices based on
what the market will bear rock car come
it's a family business serving Auto
Parts customers online for 20 years so
head on over rockauto.com right now see
all the parts available for your car or
truck right shapiro in there how did you
hear about us box so they know that we
sent you again go check them out at Rock
Auto comm that is ROC ROC ke Auto comm
right now and right Shapiro's in there
how did you hear about us box so they
know that we sent you and that's good
for them it's good for us it lets them
know that their advertisements are
working in that our audience is
listening and it's good for us in that
it shows them how well it shows them
where their customers are coming from it
shows it shows us that you are listening
the program so really appreciate it go
to rockauto.com right now go shop right
now right to appear on that how did you
hear about us box ok so I'm not the only
person who's having questions about the
models pretty much everybody at this
point is having questions about the
models according to the Associated Press
a statistical model cited by the white
house generated a slightly less grim
figure Monday for a first wave of deaths
from coronavirus pandemic in the US a
projection designed to help officials
plan for the worst including having
enough hospital staff beds and
ventilators the only problem with this
bit of relatively good news it's almost
certainly wrong all models are wrong
some are just less wrong than others and
those are the ones the public health
officials rely on NASA top climate
modeler Gavin Schmidt says the key thing
you want to know is what's happening in
the future absence a time machine you're
gonna have to use a model the latest
projections show that anywhere from
forty nine thousand four hundred thirty
one to one hundred and thirty six
thousand four hundred and one Americans
will die in the first wave which could
last into the summer which is a huge
range of 87,000 so again these models
are somewhat useful but they are not
extraordinarily useful because they are
uncertain there's a huge range on them
they're not great at modeling human
behavior and so and the biggest problem
with the model as I keep mentioning over
and over and over what this u-dub model
is that it just goes until the beginning
of August so it doesn't tell you what
happens in a second wave and we are
beginning to see even while Italy is is
flattening then even while there is
consideration being put forward toward
the toward the reopening of places like
Italy and Denmark you're starting to see
a second wave in Asia according to the
economic times
the Japanese government may declare a
state of emergency this week to contain
a
a virus outbreak Shinzo Abe a the Prime
Minister is reportedly set to make a
declaration for parts of Japan including
Tokyo as the number of people infected
with the virus continues to increase the
news pushed up Tokyo stocked with
investors seemed to move as a positive
for containing the outbreak authorities
reported 120 new virus cases on Sunday
so they're declaring an emergency in
Japan which until now had been fairly
non hard-hit also in Singapore they have
been relocking down in particular areas
that are locking down dormitory
complexes because people are coming in
and reinfecting everybody so the big
question is what happens when you start
to open this thing back up meanwhile
Italy in Norway are beginning to look at
easing their lock downs after Denmark
and Austria became the first two
European countries to loosen
restrictions as governments seek to
gradually revive economies crippled by
the containment measures without risking
a second wave of infections according to
Bloomberg Italy the original epicenter
of the outbreak has begun to plan for
merging from the lockdown selected firms
could open in mid-april according to an
official familiar with the discussions
Norway may also move to ease
restrictions with a press briefing
scheduled later on Tuesday parts of
Italy's agribusiness and health sectors
and mechanical equipment companies
linked to those industries could be
allowed to restart operations the
protection for workers will be critical
for each company involved said a person
who was talking on condition of
anonymity
after weeks of measures designed to
limit contact between people European
governments are seeing growing evidence
that shutting down much of modern life
is containing the disease but the scale
of the outbreak means officials need to
weigh any attempts to restart parts of
the economy against the risk of
reigniting the spread Europe has been
hard hit his hardest hit by the pandemic
Denmark is gonna press ahead with
cautious reopening they're gonna start
with daycare and primary schools on
April 15th if the virus numbers remain
stable the government will also start
talks with business leaders on gradually
moving employees back into offices but
with some restrictions in place for
months to come so this is where the
rubbers gonna hit the road it'll be
fascinating to see what happens in these
countries where they go back to some
level of reopening now people are all
over Sweden because Sweden has basically
allowed people to continue going to
restaurants you just don't go to the
counter instead you sit at your table
and your social distance they've allowed
people to continue going to work they've
kept their schools open and so they've
seen a jump in deaths but we're not
gonna know again the counterfactual
which is if they had locked everybody
home for a year was that going to be
better was that actually going to turn
out better again if the models are
trying to tell
that over the next few months you are
less likely to die if you stay home that
is true if the models are telling you
that over the course of the next year
you have precisely the same chance of
dying if you go out as staying in and
everybody is just going to go out and
that remains the question that no one is
willing to answer what happens with this
second wave once you got the guys to use
in place once you have the ventilators
in place once you've tested all the
drugs that you can test at least for
them for a moment then why are we not
going to a system where the people who
are the most vulnerable namely the
oldest of people have pre-existing
conditions why are we not moving to a
system where those people are basically
quarantined off for self quarantine
until we have a vaccine and everybody
else who is much lower risk goes back to
work because one of the things that
we've been seeing even in New York City
is that the the people who are dying of
Corona almost entirely have pre-existing
conditions and we are seeing the data in
that the data are are fairly clear at
this point which is that the if you are
older you have a significantly higher
rate of death if you have a pre-existing
condition you have significantly a
higher rate of death you can see this
this all these this information is
indeed available from the New York City
Government the New York City Government
is reporting in terms of rates by age
per 100,000 people if you are 75 and
older this is Kovan 19 acquisition if
you have co2 the rate that is so far
measured and again the rates not perfect
because the testing is not perfect if
you are 75 and older then out of a
hundred thousand people you have about
1.3 percent chance if you're 75 and
older of having coronavirus 1.25 percent
chance if you're 65 to 74 1.2 percent
chance if you're 45 to 64 a point 7
percent chance if you're 18 to 44 and
you have a point 6 9 percent chance if
you are 0 to 17 and if you look at
pre-existing conditions you will see
that the the number of people with
pre-existing conditions is it is fairly
obvious that people have tremendous
underlying conditions and if you are
typically going to die so I'm looking
right now at the New York City health
data from today and here's and I'll get
to what exactly that finds in just one
moment first let's talk about your
safety and security on your own property
inside your own home so
I've for a long time been worried about
safety and security on my property we
are seeing in cities around the nation
Seattle LA New York crime rates rising
as the police are overwhelmed as many of
them are staying home as people in jail
are being released instead of being put
into prison or put on trial this means
now be a pretty good time to protect
your property and this is why you need
ring ring gives you protection at every
corner helps you create custom
affordable security for your home video
doorbells let you answer the door check
in on your home anytime from anywhere
and full home security systems give you
everything you need to protect your
family pets and property with those
outdoor security cameras you can check
in on every part of your house so you're
not going to miss a moment is actually
fairly useful not even for safety
reasons but if I've got my kids playing
on the side of the house and gardening
or something I can keep an eye on them
from inside the house while I'm dealing
with the baby you get a special offer on
one rings video doorbells when you go to
ring calm / Ben right now start building
custom security for your home today head
on over to ring.com / Ben again that is
ring.com / Ben go check them out right
now ring.com / Ben yeah I've been using
them for years if I rely on them for my
security and I get lots of security
threats you should certainly be able to
rely on them for your security ring comm
/ Ben get started building that ring of
security today okay well in just a
moment we're gonna get to the statistics
from New York City again I wish there
were more transparency it seems like a
lot of the experts are trying to up play
the number of young and healthy people
who are getting this thing and dying and
downplay the number of people who are
elderly and have pre-existing conditions
who are dying and again it is it is a
enormous tragedy every time somebody
dies of any of these causes but
certainly coronavirus it's not to
downplay that but if we're going to
assess risk factors and who gets to go
back to work and who does not let's stop
pretending that every element of the
population is equally susceptible to
dying of coronavirus we'll get some more
of this in just one second first if you
haven't had a chance to see some of our
new content I'll access live you should
head over to Daley wire.com and check it
out Jeremy boring and I launched it a
couple of weeks ago originally it was
scheduled for later this summer we
accelerated it because we want to hang
out with you we understand everybody is
at home everybody is feeling lonely
everybody's feeling cutoff well we do on
all access live it's really informal
basically I just take your questions I
hang out with you sometimes I play
classical music to annoy you off of my
phone like all sorts of I wear a short
sleeve shirt which is if that's
something that you've ever thirsted for
then this would be your time if not well
too bad because I'm not gonna wear this
honestly shirt all day I've kids inside
go check us out over at Daley wire.com 8
p.m. Eastern 5:00 p.m. Pacific tonight
join us on the all-access show tonight
it is I I shall be hosting over at Daley
wire.com our all-access shows to become
a member and you can any member any
level a member is welcome at this point
later we'll cut all the off learn all
access members but in the middle of the
pandemic we're not gonna do that we're
more generous than that become a member
and hang out with us at daily where'd I
come we're the largest fastest-growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
okay so I'm gonna give you right now
some of the information about underlying
conditions in the state of new in the
city of New York they have the new york
city health data and i wish that this
data were a lot more transparent because
it doesn't actually tell you what the
underlying health conditions are and
that's freaking everybody out because a
ton of people in the united states are
overweight a ton of people are taking
statins for slightly high blood pressure
a lot of people have sort of mild
conditions are those pre-existing
conditions new york health data it
doesn't really say they say the
underlying illness has include diabetes
lung disease cancer immunodeficiency
heart disease hypertension asthma kidney
disease and Gi liver disease so that
sounds you know a lot more serious here
are the numbers on who is dying so only
two people have died under the age of 17
in New York City thus far both of them
had underlying health conditions in the
18 to 44 group 180 people have died 144
of them had underlying health conditions
only 12 had no underlying health
conditions the other 24 are still
pending testing 45 to 64 777 people dead
only 25 had no underlying health
conditions 65 to 74 789 people dead only
9 had no underlying health conditions 75
and over 1450 four people have died only
nine had no underlying conditions now
we're still waiting testing on some of
this stuff but the fact is that what
that suggests is if you have an
underlying health condition you are
severely vulnerable from this thing if
you do not have an underlying health
condition then there's an almost
extraordinary shot that you are not
going to die of this thing okay if
you're young and you're healthy and
you're out working you probably not
gonna die now you may transmit it to
other people and this is where these
studies start to come in right which is
how easily is this thing transmitted how
fast does it pass but we may get to the
point when we lock this thing down such
that the elderly are at least protected
for the moment and those who are
immunocompromised are protected at least
for the moment then we may have to say
to that group of people particularly
guys you need to stay out of the general
population you need to stay home and
listen I know how rough and terrible
that is I understand how rough and
terrible that is I really do I look my
parents right now they're 64 years old
they're in our house every day why are
they at our house every day well number
one we need to help but more importantly
we know we don't have Corona because we
had a closed-loop
for some of the stuff started we're not
super social and they've been here for
now a month basically in lockdown
nobody's got it and so that means we
have a closed loop but what happens when
we open back up right what happens when
the government says that my kids can go
back to school
well now the chances of my kids become
carriers dramatically spike right the
chance that when I go back to work and
my wife goes back to work and she's a
doctor right that the chances that she
becomes a carrier those dramatically
spike and once those spike then can my
parents be over at our house do they
have to lock themselves inside their
house up until January right all of this
stuff these are really difficult and
terrible decisions but something that
we're definitely going to have to look
at because the case remains it remains
the fact that shutting down the world
economy has pretty dire ramifications
and again everybody should be
acknowledging this at this point that
the dire ramifications of shutting down
the world economy this is not
insensitivity it is not insensitive to
think of the jobs of literally hundreds
of millions of people all over the
planet including tens of millions of
people in the United States there are
food bank lines that are literally miles
long right now in the United States for
people waiting and get flu waiting and
get food and so the question is going to
become if we are not even balancing
death right let's say for example let's
say we best possible world we knock this
thing down such that beginning of May
the rates of death from this thing are
basically twenty a day right we've
really knocked the crap out of this
thing and by the end of June we are down
to basically zero right we're really low
and then we say to the people who are
the most immunocompromised and the
elderly we say to those people you need
to stay home
we'll bring you your groceries we'll
drop them at the doorstep you need to
continue the self quarantine until you
get the vaccinations because you are the
people most likely to die and everybody
else go back to school everybody else go
back to work everybody else keep the
economy humming that may be that may be
the best we can do and these sort of
solutions that have been suggested right
people who really know what they're
talking about right Scott Gottlieb over
at the FDA who's now an adviser to
Maryland governor Larry Hogan when
people talk about contact tracing and
hundreds of thousands of tests being
done every single week and using the
South Korean model and electronic
surveillance does that seem realistic to
you in the United States seriously South
Korea has been doing this sort of stuff
for twenty years does that seem
realistic to you in the United States
and maybe better than the alternative
which is staying home but does that seem
more realistic or does it seem more
realistic to say people are gonna start
to go back to normal life
if you're vulnerable and you're elderly
we're gonna have to quarantine you off
until either herd immunity is reached or
until a vaccine is developed and right
now again people are tripping on Sweden
for taking this exact strategy but I
don't know whether Sweden is gonna pay
off
maybe Sweden does because one of the
things you're doing right now by
flattening the curve is ensuring that
more people do not get this thing which
means that people will get it in the
fall right fowey has said this is
seasonal everybody is saying this is
seasonal so what exactly is going to
happen next
that's the big question dr. Anthony
pouchy says we may never go back to
anything approaching it normal here is
the here is the head of the National
Institute for allergies and infectious
diseases back to normal means acting
like there never was a coronavirus
problem I don't think that's gonna
happen until we do have a situation
where you can completely protect the
population but when we say getting back
to normal we mean something very
different from what we're going through
right now because right now we are in a
very intense mitigation when we get back
to normal we will go back gradually to
the point where we can function as a
society and I don't know what that
gradual looks like right I don't know
what that looks like
again if you send the kids back to
school grandparents are still gonna have
to walk down
they are remin the minute my kids go
back to school grim grandpa and grandma
have to they have to walk down that's
what they have to do right that's just
the way it's gonna work I don't know
what going back to semi-normal it looks
like the minute people go back to the
office if you think they're not gonna
get reinfected I don't know what planet
you're living on right like if they say
that we have to wait till 14 days of no
cases that's not going to happen there
will not be in a country of 333 or 50
million people there's not gonna come a
point like Italy's talking about
reopening right now Italy is talking
about how they go back to a partial
reopening and Italy had like a lot of
death yesterday okay Italy still had as
of yesterday 636 deaths right they had
over 3,500 new diagnosed cases in Italy
and they're talking about reopening
right now in Norway which is talking
about reopening had five new deaths and
178 new diagnosed cases yesterday so
nobody's down to zero
the only country that says they're down
to zero is China and they're lying so
can we at some point get like a
realistic assessment of where things are
going to be III really don't think
anybody is being particularly realistic
about this stuff especially in light of
the fact that again we
not gonna keep the economy locked down
and if you really believe that people
are going to sit there and take their
$1200 check and be happy for the next
four months while losing their job
permanently if you think that I mean I
know parents in New York City right now
in their apartments with three kids
unable to go to a public park unable to
take their kids on walks and they been
locked down for three weeks you think
you're gonna be able to do that for
another three four five seven months not
going to happen not going to happen okay
meanwhile the media continued to decline
themselves and a wide variety of issues
Don Lemon objective journalist he was
really journalism a hard yesterday he
was shouting at the moon shouting at
President Trump how much more of this
are you gonna take are you mad as hell
mad as hell over what what is the thing
I'm supposed to be mad as hell over
exactly Trump saying dumb stuff welcome
to Trump world that's what he does but
I'm I suppose be mad that like foul and
Burkes I'm running the show because
those are the people the media would
like to run the show I mean Trump is
taking their advice am I supposed to be
mad that the ventilators are being
delivered they are andrew Cuomo has
thanked the White House
pretty much every day for their work
with him Gavin Newsom has been thanking
the White House every single day
Gretchen Whitmer and Michigan has been
thanking the White House every single
day like I just don't understand what we
are supposed to be so all-fired angry
about Don Lemon it doesn't make any
sense to me here's Don Lemon for the
last couple of weeks when I walk into
this building and I get in front of this
camera I swear I feel like I'm in the
movie Network I feel like Howard Beale
Americans are mad as hell okay what are
you gonna how much more can Americans
take every single day berating people
lying first it's a hoax and then I've
all along I knew it was serious I knew
it was a pandemic how much more how many
people have to die
okay I'm sorry this is it what in the
world first of all Trump never sent
Colonel varistors a hoax he said the
Democrats playing up his lack of
response was a hoax okay and then Don
Lemon says how many more people are
gonna die before he gets serious does he
look unserious he's having a press
conference with the doctors every single
day even
then the media are so eager to rip on
Trump that they are making themselves
the issue and they're losing credibility
in the process one of the big problems
here again is this a time when you
require high institutional health
tremendous institutional health we gotta
trust Congress to get us our checks we
got to trust the White House to provide
great information we got to trust the
media to be straight in their coverage
we have to trust the experts in their
modelling and nobody trusts any of these
people so it's a really difficult
problem right now and then you got down
lemon out there channeling Howard Beale
I mean for those who haven't seen the
movie by the way that is done lemon
labeling himself an insane schizophrenic
because that's what Howard Beale
actually is he thinks God is talking to
him and network so not not a great way
to compare yourself there Don Lemon but
the media are so over the top like they
interviewed yesterday I think was on CNN
they interviewed a New York City Health
Commissioner whose mother who was in her
80s died of coronavirus and this person
gets on TV and blames Trump for it do we
have the video that one I mean it's it's
it was it's it's truly astonishing this
this person gets up and they're like
well you know my mother died and Trump
has blood on his hands you are in the
New York City government there's a mayor
there his name is Bill de Blasio you got
a governor in New York State last I
checked his name is Andrew Cuomo but
somehow it's Trump spoke and solely
Trump's fault Bill DeBlasio was telling
people to go out there and party as of
early March
hey so spare me a little bit but this is
this is the media are just they're awful
at this the case in point obviously is
their coverage of this
hydroxychloroquine issue so I'm gonna
show you two clips one is from Donald
Trump the other is from Andrew Cuomo one
of these people the media hate one of
these people the media love they're
saying basically the same thing about
hydroxi here as president Trump touting
hydroxychloroquine yesterday at his
briefing you know the expression I've
used it for certain reasons what do you
have to lose what do you have to lose
and a lot of people are saying that when
and and and are taking it if you are a
doctor a nurse a first responder a
medical person going into hospitals they
say taking it before the fact is good
but what do you have to lose they say
take it I'm not looking at it one way
the other but we want to get out of this
if it does work it would be a shame if
we didn't do it early okay so first of
all he is wrong
you suggest that you ought to be taking
it preventatively right there's not
evidence that you ought to be taking
this thing preventatively that you
should be taking what that is a legit
fact check if president from says you
ought to be taking this thing
preventatively you should not be saying
that right it should be prescribed by a
doctor when it is useful okay but him
touting the benefits of
hydroxychloroquine the media have more
broadly suggested it is very bad to tout
the benefits of hydroxychloroquine and
yet here you have Andrew Cuomo yesterday
suggesting there's anecdotal evidence
and we're going to ask for more of it
there has been an atonal evidence that
it is promising that's why we're going
ahead doctors have to prescribe but
there are some people who have
pre-existing conditions where it doesn't
work or they're taking medication that's
not consistent with this treatment but
anecdotally it's been positive we'll
have a full test once they have a large
enough sample and data said Jesse but
anecdotally it's been positive okay so
he's saying also that there is some
benefits to the drug a michigan Democrat
yesterday
hey mountains had hydroxy saved my life
hydroxychloroquine save my life she
thanked president Trump for that right
so and this has led the this has led the
media to lose their mind the worst story
from the New York Times this is amazing
so the New York Times is covering
hydroxychloroquine and saying Trump is
pumping it in all of this so why is from
pumping this so the obvious answer is
that Trump is trying to give people hope
for a treatment that is short of a
ventilator and death right that is the
short answer that he's looking at
anecdotal evidence he is seeing
anecdotal evidence there are small
studies that suggest that this thing is
at least somewhat effective some say
mildly effective some say more than
mildly effective and Trump is trying to
give people a ray of hope in the midst
of a really really dark time right that
is the most logical explanation that is
not where the New York Times goes
instead cures the New York Times
reporting if hydroxychloroquine becomes
an accepted treatment several
pharmaceutical companies stand to profit
including shareholders and senior
executives with connections to the
president mr. Trump himself has a small
personal financial interest in Sanofi
the French drug maker the mix Plaquenil
the brand-name version of
hydroxychloroquine um so you think that
Trump is pushing a hydroxychloroquine
cuz he owns stock in a company that
makes plaque one out first of all this
thing's off patent hydroxychloroquine is
not on pad
which means that the maker of Plaquenil
is not the company that stands to
benefit most second of all how big a
staked his Trump own in Sanofi according
to market watch his three family trusts
have investments in a Dodge and Cox
mutual fund whose largest holding is
Sanofi Trump's 2019 a financial
disclosure formalist stakes in family
trust one two and three valued between a
thousand bucks and fifteen thousand
bucks
so if Trump has the maximum $15,000 in
each of the trusts he holds a stake in
Sanofi that's worth fourteen hundred
eighty-five dollars at at the minimum
ninety-nine bucks you're right probably
Trump who's the very least worth a
billion dollars
heman people with 10 billion he's worth
at least a billion you're saying that
that guy is recommending
hydroxychloroquine because the on-brand
version now that we are off patent that
that brand version he needs that to sell
because of his 99 dollar stake in the
company that's what's happening here
that's your chief explanation I'm sorry
that it's just ridiculous it's just
ridiculous but the ridiculousness of the
media has there they're blowing their
own credibility they really are and now
is not the time to blow your credibility
now would be the time for some
responsible reportage
all righty time for a quick thing I like
and then we'll get to some things that I
hate so things that I like today so when
you are cooped up long enough with small
children eventually you take to
physically throwing them around and
that's pretty much what has happened in
my house I have a six year old and a
three year old and their favorite game
right now is for me to take out my phone
and put on Aussie Osbourne's crazy train
and then proceed to air a guitar with
them as human beings not like the air
guitar with me like I physically picked
them up and they become the guitar and
it's it's a fun thing to do they've
really been enjoying that that my
daughter particular likes the drum solo
and she has long hair so she can really
headbang along to Ozzy Osbourne so in
honor of the only person who has eaten a
bat and not gotten kovat apparently here
is a little bit of crazy trained by Ozzy
Osbourne I get a lot of people who ask
me about do I listen to like hard rock
music a couple good songs crazy trains
pretty great song
I wish I had my Finnegan waiting for
right now and then you pick them like
wait a minute you and then right now
you really go for it it's a great song
honestly I don't like God's guys going
to music all that much you know my price
is the song free fantastic yeah okay so
you know if you're in that kind of mood
and I think everybody is you don't want
to go Howard Beale go Ozzy Osbourne just
don't eat the bad guys no eating of the
bats regardless of color or culture no
eating of the bats okay other things
that I like today I do love rich irony
here's the enriched irony the founder of
BDS which is boycotts investments and
sanctions from Israel his name is Omar
about booty he is awful he wants to
destroy the State of Israel has made
this absolutely clear from the outset
now he says that if Israel does create
the vaccine for coronavirus that BDS
supporters can take it weird your
principals went directly out the window
when it turns out that Israel made
something you want to use who could have
predicted such a thing he said according
to the Jerusalem Post if you use medical
equipment from Israel it's not a problem
cooperating with Israel against the
virus to begin with that's not
normalization the BDS announced
normalization criteria long ago if
Israel finds a cure for cancer for
example or any other virus there's no
problem in cooperating with Israel to
save millions of lives up until now
we've not been in a situation where we
need Israel urgency and no one le and no
one else can save us but Israel if that
happens saving lives is more important
than anything else
Oh weird weird how like all of your
Israel is very bad we won't use any of
the products went directly out of the
window as soon as you wanted to use one
of their products very odd how that
worked so I only hope that this
materializes not only because everybody
wants the vaccine and that'd be great
but also because it would be absolutely
delicious to watch all the BDS people
have to acknowledge that their garbage
strategy has indeed failed so I think
that would be quite good learning time
for a quick thing that I hate remember
the time there is this guy's name was
judge a Brett Kavanaugh and there's a
trial in the Senate they would not try
was a hearing for him or a confirmation
hearing for him in the Senate Judiciary
Committee and everything was going
fairly swimmingly in fact I was not
particularly high on drugs Brett
Kavanaugh as the Supreme Court pick I
thought he was too wishy-washy I was
suspicious that he was not going to be
as originalist
as a Justice Thomas for example and then
things went sideways and the way they
went sideways is that a woman came
forward him Christine Blasi Ford and she
said that some four decades ago
that this person had allegedly attempted
to rape her at a party and nobody came
forward with any corroborating details
she herself could not say the night she
herself could not say where it was
she herself improperly named the people
who were there all of whom denied having
been there her allies attempted to
pressure some of the witnesses at this
thing that did not stop Alyssa Milano
star of the the Magnificent unparalleled
TV show charmed it did not stop Alyssa
Milano from showing up and like wearing
Handmaid's Tale outfits and sitting
behind Brett Kavanaugh because hashtag
me - ladies hash tag me - and when
people like Alyssa Milano were asked
specifically about you know this thing
called you process where you have to
provide evidence of an allegation to
make us take it a little bit more
seriously than the mere allegation
itself it was this is because you just
don't believe all women if only you
believed all women if only you weren't a
vicious sexist trying to control all
women into being childbearing sounds
then you would have just accepted at
face value any accusation made about any
man anywhere well speaking of hypocrisy
it turns out that there is a woman who
has now come forward and she's accused
the the former vice president of the
United States of a sexual assault
right so the so this woman his name is
Tara Reid not the actress pretty
different person she was an intern for
four Biden's office and she alleges that
Biden basically pushed her up against a
wall and then tried to go under her
skirt and actually touched her genitals
forcibly and then when she told him not
that he sort of backed off well Alyssa
Milano is a big backer of Joe Biden and
she did a a radio show yesterday in
which she explained why she had not
spoken out about the sexual assault
allegation it turns out that believe all
women goes completely by the wayside as
soon as it's somebody that she likes so
here was Alyssa Milano explaining why
she was not going to give any credence
to the allegations the obvious answer is
she's not giving credence to the
allegations because she doesn't like the
allegations I believe that um even
though we should believe women and that
is an important thing and what that
statement really means is like you know
for so long the the
goto has been not to believe them so
really we have to sort of societally
change that mindset to believing women
but that does not mean at the expense of
not you know giving men their due
process um
what now wait wait did you stumble over
due process it's like she was walking
along the road and there was a due
process right there and boom just
stumbled right upon it
who could have suggested long ago that
due process would have been a good idea
well not Alyssa Milano right she
actually continued she say investigate
situations it's got it's got to be fair
in both directions so I've been very
vocal about Biden my support for him
I've known him for a long time I did my
due diligence because part of it was
that the article that sort of stood out
to me was that times up decided not to
take the case well so so what if times
I've decided not to take the case does
that mean that the woman is lying what
interest does she have in line we were
told that Christine Blasi Ford had no
interest in making things up if there
was no possibility she was miss
remembering that there was no
possibility at all that memories from 40
years ago are vague or confusing or
anything like that it was crystal clear
in her memory and other allegations
which required lawyers to basically
convince people to go out and say things
right there's another allegation where a
woman had to meet six times with her
lawyer in order to accuse Brett
Kavanaugh of something that was
perfectly good evidence that Brett
Kavanaugh was indeed a rapist right she
says I don't just feel comfortable
throwing away a decent man I've known
for 15 years in this time of complete
chaos without there being a thorough
investigation I'm sure that the
mainstream media would be jumping all
over this as well if if you know if they
found more evidence so I'm just staying
quiet about it i sympathy meets you
tweet over two years ago I never thought
it would be something that's gonna
destroy innocent men right we don't want
that to happen either so we have to find
this balance in the believe women
movement and also giving men their due
process realizing that we're destroying
lives if we publicly don't go through
the right steps in order to find out if
an accusation is credible or not okay in
in September 2018 here's what she had to
say les Milano let me be as clear as
possible I believe Christine Blasi Ford
Adam and our senators vote to reject
Brett Kavanaugh as the next justice on
the Supreme Court every person who
refuses to loudly an openly reject Brad
Cavanaugh's nomination is telling every
generation of Americans that an alleged
abusers career is more valuable than the
survivors humanity the highest court
and is no place for an alleged sexual
offender said about the White House how
about the White House is that a good
place for an alleged sexual offender to
sit and also it seems to me that if this
is the standard for Brett Kavanaugh it
should it should be the standard for you
but apparently not apparently shocker
shock of shocks Alyssa Milano is a giant
hypocrite and the me to standards only
apply to people that we don't like
everybody else we do like at that point
we just called them trailer-trash people
who if you drag a hundred-dollar bill
through it through a trailer park then
yeah then you pick up people like this
which is what James Carville suggested
suggested about the alleged victims of
Bill Clinton so yes me too
and due process Alyssa Milano
rediscovering due process pretty
delicious alrighty we'll be back here a
little bit later today with two
additional hours of content and all your
updates also all access live tonight so
I'll be hanging out with you for an hour
taking all your questions maybe 45
minutes because I don't want to hang out
with you that long but at the very least
we'll hang out for 45 minutes before my
screaming children come in and invade
the place otherwise we'll see you here
tomorrow i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring
supervising producer
Mathis Glover and Robert Stirling
assistant director Pavel I douse key
technical producer Austin Stevens
playback and media operated by Nick
Sheehan associate producer Katie Swinton
edited by Adam SIA vets audio is mixed
by mic poor amina hair and makeup is by
NECA geneva the ben shapiro show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20 Alyssa Milano believes all
women except for the women accusing her
friends of sexual assault we will
examine how the me to movement died
yesterday and what lessons we can learn
from its demise on everything from
politics to the coronavirus then more
good news out of New York more bad news
for the fake news media and a Bernie bro
endorsement for president Trump all that
and more check it out in the Michael
Knowles show
[Music]